[Música]
hace un año el 24 de febrero de 2022 las
fuerzas armadas rusas invadieron Ucrania
durante varios meses estuvimos en
contacto con ucranianos en todo el país
y ante la prolongación del conflicto les
preguntamos Cómo la guerra ha cambiado
sus vidas nuestro observador taras
reunet decidió quedarse en kiev cuidado
de mis padres porque ambos son
discapacitados por eso decidimos
quedarnos en kiev
cuando los rusos empezaron a
bombardearnos a finales de febrero
utilizamos los refugios antibombas
varias veces pero luego mi padre se
rindió porque le era muy difícil caminar
en general hay cortes de Electricidad
Durante los días laborales
en promedio duran entre 3 y 5 horas al
día
en otoño utilicé sobre todo velas y
hornillos para cocinar huevos por
ejemplo
ritmo
nuestro peor corte de Electricidad fue a
finales de noviembre
duró tres días
Muchas tiendas se quedaron Sin comida el
último gran bombardeo ocurrió el 31 de
diciembre
varias personas murieron en kiev pero
desde entonces no hemos tenido grandes
bombardeos ni cortes de electricidad
me considero afortunado porque tengo un
techo pan en la mesa y en general buena
salud Eso es lo único que importa en
este punto desde el comienzo de la
guerra alrededor de 8 millones de
personas han huido de Ucrania para
refugiarse en el extranjero entre ellas
está nuestra observadora Verónica Tico
newk que actualmente se encuentra en
macedonia del Norte ella abandonó Mario
Paul Poco después de que comenzara la
invasión
El ruido de los bombardeos y las
explosiones Se oía muy cerca y el sonido
se acercaba más cada hora
entonces supimos que teníamos que
abandonar la ciudad atravesamos enormes
calles entre las ruinas los coscumbres
de metal
vidrio y basura de los edificios
destruidos en las calles había autos
destruidos en llamas
fuimos a saporilla ni Pro luego
atravesamos el país hasta el VIP
después fuimos a buscart y de ahí a un
pueblo en las montañas
nuestra observadora finalmente llegó a
macedonia del Norte con unos amigos
actualmente vivo con mi mamá estudia a
distancia y estoy terminando el tercer
año de carrera
también trabajo a distancia
Sinceramente ya no tengo vida
claro que estoy vivo pero aunque la
guerra acabara ahora mismo mi casa está
destruida
todo lo que me importa como la
universidad el deporte yo era jugadora
de hockey sobre hielo mi equipo mi pista
mis amigos todo eso ya no existe
desde que Rusia invadió Ucrania nuestra
redacción ha detectado diariamente
informaciones falsas que recurren a
fotos o a videos modificados y un tema
que ha surgido frecuentemente es que en
el espacio Público de los países
occidentales supuestamente habría
mensajes que critican el apoyo a Ucrania
su objetivo es hacer creer que la
opinión pública de occidente no apoya
necesariamente al gobierno de Ucrania
veamos por ejemplo este vídeo difundido
el pasado mes de noviembre
vemos el Times Square de Nueva York y en
la pantalla gigante aparece un anuncio
que se burla del presidente ucraniano
bolodimir selenski en este se le compara
con un agujero negro término utilizado
normalmente en las publicaciones Pro
rusas que afirman que el mandatario está
captando el dinero de occidente Pero hay
varios problemas con este video primero
puede verse el logo de Fox news digital
división de la cadena estadounidense del
mismo nombre Fox news nos dijo que nunca
emitió este anuncio y algo similar
ocurre con el Museo de Historia Natural
de Nueva York cuyo nombre aparece al
final del anuncio y con quien también
nos pusimos en contacto sus responsables
denuncian la desinformación que hace uso
del logotipo del Museo de hecho no hay
pruebas de la existencia de este anuncio
primero nadie grabó la misma escena
desde otro ángulo y por otra parte los
únicos medios de comunicación que lo
transmitieron Son medios rusos con una
narrativa procremlin o páginas de
Facebook como la de la embajada rusa en
y este no es el único ejemplo de un
supuesto anuncio mostrada en pantalla
gigante este fue visto supuestamente en
el metro de Varsovia en Polonia E invita
a los polacos a ir a luchar a Ucrania
para conducir tanques según las cuentas
prorrusas o los medios de comunicación
que compartieron el video esto
demostraría plenamente las ambiciones
imperiales de Varsovia una acusación que
Moscú hace a menudo para criticar el
hecho de que Polonia le suministre armas
a su vecino Ucrania le mostramos este
video a janes Marín investigador en
análisis de imagen y esto nos contó si
el anuncio es real probablemente se
puedan encontrar Rastros de él a través
de las ventanas del metro Así que hice
un análisis fotograma a fotograma
primero pude ver la línea horizontal en
la pared de la Estación de metro
luego pude ver el borde del anuncio y un
texto escrito en el borde pude verlo a
través de las ventanas del metro
y entonces vimos la zona publicitaria
pero no encontramos ningún rastro del
tanque verde ni del texto rojo solo la
zona Blanca
esto nos hace pensar que el anuncio es
en realidad falso
En conclusión todos estos anuncios
forman parte de la estrategia de
narrativas alternativas sobre la guerra
en Ucrania difundidas por cuentas
prorrusas que se basan en anuncios que
fueron modificados gráficamente y que
nunca han sido emitidos al menos
oficialmente
[Música]
hasta aquí llega este episodio Gracias a
todos nuestros observadores que nos
envían sus testimonios usted también
puede hacer parte del programa envíenos
imágenes o vídeos a los contactos que
aparecen en su pantalla hasta la próxima
semana